Vi går igång så mycket på när folk klagar på vår kvalitet och pratar om hur det funkar med parfym.
Och man bara, ni har ingen aning om...
Nischparfym är många gånger bara bullshits.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni omsökt en 160 minuter.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rendesbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men...
Alltså man tar det positivt.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Jonna på SMs till på The Makes Sweden Stronger.
Och du har ju gjort en helt bizarr företagsresa.
Välkommen Jonna.
Känns det som att du har stigit in på arenan och bara sagt att här är jag nu?
Ja, jag har ju ändå varit såhär lite dålig i e-handelsvärde eller så jag har varit med i det här nätverket på Svensk Handel.
Det var jag liksom innan jag startade i princip.
Så jag känner att de som vet, de har vetat.
Och de som inte har vetat kanske vet nu när det har blivit lite mer uppmärksammat i media och vi hade ju en artikel i Dei här i våras och så.
Nu kanske många vet vilka vi är.
Men känner du dig som en företagsledare liksom?
Alltså det gör jag ju inte.
Alltså jag kategoriserar mig nästan ibland mer som typ så här influencer eller så.
Alltså jag har ju liksom blivit, jag blir ju igenkänd när jag är ut och träffar få.
Alltså sen när jag är på konserter och då är det jättemånga som kommer fram och bara åh jag älskar det du gör, jag älskar dina parfymer.
Så jag känner ju mer typ kategoriserad som en så här influencer-entrepreneur än en så här företagsledare.
För min roll på Essence är ju också, jag äger bolaget, men jag vill inte vara chef.
Jag har inget personalföransvar.
Det är inte där jag besitter kunskap och det är inte där jag kommer att utveckla bolaget genom att utveckla min personal.
Det är klart att jag måste vara med på de delarna, men där har jag ju tagit in min sambo som är vd.
Jag anställer en tjej, det var den första tjejen, in på kontorsdelen.
Hon är marknadsansvarig nu.
Hon och jag har jättebra dialog och henne är jag liksom...
Vd är fortfarande hennes närmsta chef, men jag har ju want once med henne och jag är ändå hennes stöd.
Men jag klarar inte av att klara av.
Men jag känner mig inte som en företagskledare.
Jag fattar.
Bara för att man ska sätta där.
För de som inte känner till er, ni har gjort dina resa, jag tror att jag har ungefär siffrorna rätt, men ni gick från 5 miljoner till 23 miljoner till 84 miljoner eller något sånt där.
Det är en helt absurd utveckling och den är ännu mer absurd om man tänker på att ni gjorde rätt bra vinst på sista raden.
Det var liksom inte 5-10 procent som folk hoppas på utan betydligt mer.
Kan du nästan känna en press att ni ska fortsätta växa i den takten?
Eller är ni såhär, det är lugnt att vi gör detta för vår skull.
För nu någonstans har ni dykt upp här i ramphjuset och då är det nästan som att man såhär, wow, det här kommer bara dra till stratosfären liksom.
Alltså vi har ju alltid haft en väldigt chill inställning till det.
Eller såhär, för jag kommer ju från ganska stora bolag, jag jobbade på Nordic Feel som sen blev typ Eleven Group, så nu är det en merge av flera sådana beautybolag.
Jag jobbade en liten liten stund på Wacacoo, som också är en lite större e-handel för de exklusiva brands vi klädd med.
Och sen när jag jobbade på TurnRebel.
Och jag känner, när jag startade Sense, så var det en liten sidewisney.
Tanken var väl inte att det skulle bli såhär som vi blev.
Och vi har en väldigt humble inställning.
Alltså vi är så, eller jag är så, varför är alla så himla kåta på att växa?
Eller så här, jag bara, men jag vet inte, vi har det skitbra.
Men det händer ju någonting med en när man växer.
Jag vet när jag jobbar på TurnRebel, jag bara, varför vill de in i nya marknader?
Det går ju skitbra här där vi är typ.
Och sen nu sitter jag här och bara, Loree, Holland, EU, USA, ska vi till USA?
Man blir ju knäpp och jag är en tävlingsmänniska.
Jag är inte så här, jag är lite idrotta så jag är ju en tävlingsmänniska.
Men jag försöker någonstans bara så här, okej andas, vi ska ha ett bra liv, vi har två barn.
Jag vill att alla mina anställda ska liksom, det här ska vara deras bästa.
När de byter jobb, det är då de kommer inse hur sjukt bra vi har det typ, för att vara en e-handel.
För det är så här, om jag säger ofta att tjejerna är bara, vi är inga läkare, vi behöver inte rädda några liv, om det händer någonting som inte är rätt, skitsamma.
Alltså det är så här, ingen kommer dö.
Och den inställningen, den har ju fortfarande någonstans.
Och jag är typ så här, skulle vi inte växa i år, vilket jag vet att vi kommer, men skulle vi inte det så är jag ändå fine med det.
Men någonstans inom en vill man ju liksom, man vill ju utvecklas och man vill ju framåt och man vill ju liksom bli bättre.
Så jag vet inte, det är liksom en turdelad fråga, men vi går ju inte över lik för att vi behöver inte tillväxt.
För vi har inte byggt vår organisation på det sättet.
Ni har ju en extremt snabb tillväxt, finns det någon nackdel med det?
Nu får du tänka att jag luskar nästan utifrån egen intresse här, eftersom min tillväxt har ju varit långsam.
Och då undrar jag, har jag haft något syfte med att växa långsamt här under, det som ni har gjort på tre år har jag gjort på tolv år.
Fanns det någon anledning för mig att göra det här på tolv år?
Och jag tror att ni gör mer vinst på ett år än vad jag har gjort sammanlagt under hela det här.
För alla är ju alltid såhär, man ska tänka på att bygga stabilt och man ska ändå bygga för hållbarhet och långsiktigt.
Är det bara bullshitt?
Finns det någonting man saknar när man växer fort?
Det behöver inte betyda att det behöver gå långsamt.
Jag har ju tänkt att vi vill ju inte bara vara en hype.
Sen fattar jag att vi är lite hype just nu och det är därför jag är ganska ödmjuka inför att vår omsättning kanske inte kommer att stiga den takten där jag har gjort från år 0-3.
När du säger att vi är en hype nu, vad menar du med att det är en hype?
Vad är det som inte skulle göra att det fortsätter?
Jag tänker att när det kommer nya grejer så blir det alltid så.
Det blir väldigt hett i början.
Alltså det kan man ju se på alla konsumentprodukter eller de flesta går ju i liksom, alltså livscyklar kan man säga.
Gucci är ju skittrendigt ett tag.
Sen är inte Gucci trendigt längre utan då kommer något annat.
Men sen kommer Gucci tillbaka.
Och lite så tänker jag att vår resa kommer att vara, just nu är det, dels är det jättetrendigt med parfym.
Vi är ett nytt varumärke som är väldigt trendigt.
Sen kanske inte vi har nått vår peak än.
Men när vi har nått vår peak då kommer det gå ner för att sen komma tillbaka och gå upp tror jag.
Men kan du uppleva att andra företag börjar liksom gå mot, när ni kom in så var ni lite halvunika, ni var ju extremt, eller du kanske är extremt öppen mot kunden, ni gör ju även filmer där ni liksom snackar om.
Det här tycker vi inte var en bra parfym.
Alltså det är ju rätt ovanligt som företag att köra på det sättet.
Och så har ni en viss prissättning och ni jobbar på ett visst sätt.
Märker ni att andra företag börjar liksom zooma in på er marknad?
Det är klart för det är ju, jag tänkte att kunderna efterfrågar transparans.
Och då vill ju företagslået också möta det.
Jag tror att det är svårt att bygga någonting.
Jag brukar typ kategorisera lite instagrambrands.
Det är liksom de som har det här fina flödet på instagram, de har inte varit personliga innan, ingen har en aning om vem som är bakom de här företagen.
Och sen helt plötsligt börjar de göra content som att de är typ en buddy.
Det rimmar inte.
Då måste de tänka om, de måste hålla sig till sin format och sen anpassa det till TikTok.
Och de måste möta sin transparens situation.
De kommer att ha en annan transparens relation till kunderna än vad vi har.
Vi kan vara mer så.
Vi är liksom som en influencer på TikTok för att vi är födda där.
Alla vi, alltså min Amanda som har jobbat hos oss ett år, hon var på konsert i helgen, hon bara, nej alltså det var ju så många som kom fram och vet vem jag är.
Och hon är ju så bara en vanlig tjeja från Småland.
Alltså man blir liksom in, sen när man jobbar, alla är liksom med på att, alla är inte med på att bli filmade, vi är extra beredda att de inte vill bli filmade, men de flesta som blir helt i en sådan ställe är ju medvetna om att man kommer in här och man är liksom en del av vårt sociala medieteam typ.
Vi har ju inte en person som är anställd för att jobba med TikTok.
Alla på marknad redigerar TikTok-videos.
Det är så här att portionera sig ut på måndags mötet, du redigerar dem, du redigerar dem, du redigerar dem, för att liksom alla ska ha örat moturellsen på just TikTok-plattformen.
Är du mer rädd för att TikTok ska bli banat?
De hade ju hela det, nu har ju de ju hållit på åtta gånger här i USA, men är det någonting som håller dig vaken på nätterna?
Nej absolut inte.
Alltså typ kunden är ju där kunden är.
TikTok har blivit det formatet som är enkelt att snacka till kunden.
Jag menar att vi har 50 000 följare på Instagram och får ganska mycket spridning på våra reels som vi lägger ut där.
Så jag är inte, och då återigen, om det skulle vara så så har vi vår kundbas och då får vi hitta andra sätt att kommunicera med dem.
Jag tänker på, om jag bara hoppar tillbaka, det finns dessutom lite för mycket att snacka om, men om jag hoppar tillbaka, som sagt ni har ju vuxit väldigt väldigt fort.
Känner du att ni har skarvat på någonting?
Är det någonting du känner att det där är vi inte i kapp med?
Nej, jag skulle precis berätta klart om det då.
Det bygger ju inte essent som att vi ska såhär, om vi ska bli den hype och sen så kan det hända vad som helst och vi ska exita typ.
Alltså vi bygger, jag bygger det långsiktigt, sen är det typ så att jag brukar säga att det är att sitta i flumride och det bara rakt ner och det bara skvätter.
Det är liksom att den effekten har kommit där vi sitter ändå såhär stabilt i vår lilla flumride och vi försöker bygga det för att det inte ska vara den här hypen och det ska dö, utan vi vill ju vara ett varumärke som finns med långsiktigt och vi har ju aldrig rabatter som är ett steg i vår långsiktiga strategi.
Jag kommer från bolag där det är rabattkod på rabattkod och vi brukar alltid säga att det är liksom som heroin för din business.
Alltså när du har börjat då är det jävligt svårt att sluta och du måste fortsätta pumpa för att ha effekt.
Så vi bygger ju inte sen som att det ska vara något så kortsiktigt, utan vi försöker ändå, även att det har gått så fort på de här korta åren, så försöker vi bygga det långsiktigt, stabilt och vi bygger ju, de flesta kampanjer vi gör är ju liksom varumärketskampanjer.
Jag är väldigt fascinerad över era prisstrategi ur flera aspekter.
Ofta när folk säger att vi jobbar inte med rabatter och sånt så har man ju ändå rabatter på typ 25 procent av sortimenten.
Alltså typ när man säljer ut grejer.
Men ni har ju, jag tror inte jag hittar ändå rabatter på er hemsida när jag kikar där.
Vi har aldrig haft det.
Hur blir ni av med överlager och saker ni vill sälja?
Det blir vi.
Okej, ni bara skiter i det.
Ja men helt ärligt, jag siktar ju min kött.
Och jag har ju börjat inse mina begränsningar om man säger så.
Jag satt här i veckan och bara, nu har vi väldigt mycket i lager.
Förra året, alltså i december, typ 25 december, det var ju typ tomt på allt.
Och i år var det så att vi ska inte gå torsk, så vi har jobbat nu för att bunkra lager sen årsskiftet.
Så vi ligger, på vissa rutor har vi lite för mycket lager kan man säga.
Men jag känner, jag vet inte vad jag känner riktigt.
Jag vet inte riktigt vad vi ska göra om det nu är så att vi inser att det är över lager på en del produkter.
Men vi har ju väldigt bra kastarfröde och det påverkar ju inte vår kassa på det sättet.
Sen är det såklart inte nice att ha för mycket produkter.
Men vi, jag vet inte.
Det är en fråga som jag inte riktigt vet svar på.
Men parfym blir inte gammalt på det sättet?
Nej men man har ju ändå typ, vi har att såhär, vi vill väl egentligen inte att det ska stå på lag mer än tre år.
Men vi har liksom väldigt schyssta, när du jobbar inom beauty då är ju ofta minst årdifantiteten mellan fem och tio tusen per produkt.
Så har ju inte vi haft det när vi har jobbat.
Vissa produkter i början kunde jag beställa, jag vill inte prata något antal men det är ju inte många.
Nu är ju våra, det minsta vi beställer av en produkt är med pallvis, så nu är det ju inte så som det var i början.
Men det har ju varit en väldigt tacksam partner som vi har jobbat med, som inte gjort att vi behövt tömma kassan på lager, utan att vi har kunnat hålla i det.
Och sen första året betalade ju, eller vi gjorde inga betalda annonser det året vi omsatte fem miljoner, det var ju bara organiskt tillväxt.
Jag tror inte heller att jag tog ut någon lön i bolaget under första året, så vi byggde ju väldigt bra kassa.
Och så vet jag att jag pratar med vissa entreprenörer om, när du behöver omsätta mycket, då blir snöbollen större, och då kommer du behöva ta in pengar, och du behöver ta in investerare, det kommer aldrig att ha råd med lagret.
Och jag var såhär, ha, jag fattar inte det då, jag bara, okej, ja ja.
Men jag inser också att om vi säljer mer, så känner vi också mer.
Vi har ju alltid haft våra kostnadseffektiva tänk.
Jag är smålänning så in i helvete.
Det är ju det som gör att det ser ut så som det gör på våra kost.
Ja.
Du sa att ni bunkrade parfym.
Är parfym något som tar lång tid att tillverka?
I mitt huvud är det bara såhär, jag blandar ihop ett par grejer och skickar iväg det.
Men det är inte så det funkar.
Jo men alltså, vi jobbar ju med ett familjeparfymeri i södra Frankrike.
Så där är det ju såhär, vi behöver ju ha en viss framförhållning och förståelse för att allt vårt blandas ju för hand.
Idag finns det ju såhär jätteavancerad teknologi för att blanda, det är ju datoriserat liksom.
Men så jobbar inte vi.
Så vi har en person som både utvecklar våra nya produkter och han är så, de har tagit in en till så de har anställt en till näsa.
Men den näsan jobbar inte, han får typ inte jobba med våra grejer för vår befintliga näsa för han är så.
Jag måste assur the quality.
Gör du minsta lilla grammet fel så blir det ju en annan doft.
Gick utvecklingen lite för fort för det där familjestället i Frankrike?
Hade de inte räknat med?
Nej, gubben som ägde, jag har jobbat med honom sen 2016, 2017.
Jag tog fram parfymen med influencers när jag jobbade på Nordic Phil.
Så då var ett influencerprojekt med Bianca Ingrosso var ju med i den här leverantören.
Då började vi jobba och jag var typ 22.
Jag var ju så jätteliten om jag ser på mig själv nu.
Han har jobbat med hela den resan och sett min utveckling.
Men han säger ju alltid typ såhär, jag har alltid sett att du har det i dig.
Han vill ju ta på sig lite äran att de har varit där som partner.
Det är verkligen, vi är ju typ familj med dem.
Vi var ju nere förra sommaren med hela min familj och vi bodde där nere och gick ut åt med dem varje kväll och var på hans båt.
Alltså vi har blivit som familj.
Det är det som är lite jobbigt för det gör ju det jobbigare för oss.
Att vi kanske hade egentligen, hade jag inte varit jag utan bara tänkt på business, då hade vi haft en till fabrik.
För det hade vi behövt.
Men det tar så mycket emot att de vill växa med oss.
Visst det tar kanske lite längre tid men det blir väldigt roligt när man får liksom, men det är ingen annan riktigt som kan göra det vi gör.
Alltså det är inget som kommer få en sån relation med någon tillverkare.
Jag går runt i labbet och får dofta på allt.
Det är ju inte röm i sig för oss.
Det är skitkul att kunna vara så nära produktionen.
Det är inte bara datorer utan det är ju verkliga människor som vi har fått jättelå relationer med som är på ledet innan oss som kunden får ta del av.
Ja, men när du säger att det finns en begränsning, är det produktionshastigheten som är en begränsning?
Ja, men också strukturellt.
Det är det som är svårt för de löser grejer som ingen annan hade gjort.
De skickar in dem på en lördag för att göra någonting som gör att vi på måndag kan få produkterna.
Medan en vanlig fabrik hade varit 9-month-delivery, eller så långt är det inte.
Man får räkna med minst ett halvår hos andra och vi kan få våra grejer i bästa världar inom två månader.
Ibland en vecka om det så att vi har olja sparat.
Så det är en het diskussion hur vi ska ta oss framåt med det här, men vi vill ju så gärna jobba med dem så att det är svårt att hitta någon annan.
Jag kan förstå den konflikten.
Jag har själv suttit i sådana konflikttankar och så sitter man och tänker typ fan om jag bara inte hade den här moraliska kompassen och var mycket lätt.
Livet hade varit.
Samtidigt så finns det ju en charm i det såklart som det säger.
Om de är ändå så snabba, vad är det som innebär att ni får de här överlagren?
Är det för att du inte har jobbat med inköp innan?
Ja, jag har ju inga av alla.
Det har ju fungerat sjukt bra hittills för vi har ju sålt så mycket.
Men nu vet jag ju att vi har en chokladparfym och den såldes som fan när vi lanserade.
Och jag bara shit, vi måste blanda med er, de du vet samma dag, blanda med er.
Och sen bara kommer recensionen och en alla bara den luktar skit.
Och vi inser ju också att den luktar ju inte skit, men den luktar ju skit mycket choklad.
Och den är så stark.
Vi hade ju på papprutiker och man var så spränt med den.
Den spräver den på filmen.
Den är skitnajs om man gillar choklad.
Men den såldes ju på grund av att det var en hajp då.
Alla ville ha den när man lanserade, man var rädda att den skulle ta slut.
Men sen var den inte så bra.
Och då hade vi redan...
Så jag tror att vi har väl fyra år på den eller någonting i lager.
Jag förstår, ni får ta en ny marknad.
Ja, men alltså vi är ju inne i EU nu och EU är ju heta på den.
De är ju intresserade av den chokladparfumen typ.
Men jag vet ju också, i år behöver vi inte oroa mig, men nästa år behöver vi, okej vad gör vi med den?
Ska vi skänka den till någon så...
Jag vet inte.
Eller ska vi då börja ha någon form av, jag vet inte vad man ska kalla det, samplesale som många säger då.
Jag vet inte, vi har ingen plan för det men jag vill ju inte rabattera för det går så mycket emot...
Sen finns det ju, när man har det som en samplesale eller utförsäljning eller sådana grejer, då har det ju ett annat syfte än att driva försäljning.
Det är ju mer för att rädda mig att jag har en samplesale eller en utförsäljning eller vad man vill kalla det.
Och inte ett sätt att sälja massa.
Jag förstår absolut.
Det är intressant, det ska bli...
Det skulle nästan vara ett uppföljningsavsnitt om två år när ni sitter i den situationen, för det är ju en spännande...
Jag tycker det är en väldigt intressant fråga hur man blir av med överlager.
Man får ju bara helt enkelt inte skaffa sig något överlager, tänker jag.
Exakt så.
I den bästa av världar.
Ni har ju också en prissättning där ni...
Jag tror att de flesta av era parfiner kostar typ 360 spänn.
Det är ju en skumssiffra.
Varför har ni valt?
Varför kostar de inte 350?
Eller 349?
Varför har ni valt 360?
Jag vet inte.
Jag är ingen rörig.
Det blev så.
Okej.
Det började på 320-325 tror jag.
Då kände jag att det här låter för billigt.
För det är...
Det handlar på hjärtat så är det så jävla bra.
Du märker ingen skillnad på våra parfymer och en dyr parfym.
Du kan absolut märka skillnaden.
Vår parfym sitter sämre än den dyra parfymen.
Men det finns vissa dyra...
Vad menar du sitter?
Att den inte håller sig lika länge?
Men vi får ju ofta kritik för det.
Jag tänkte säga, tror du inte att föräldrar är ganska glada för det?
Det är inte barn som köper produkter.
Vår mål är ju 25-35.
Men det jag menar är att när folk går in, när man har köpt något billigt, då är man ofta väldigt gärna skeptisk.
Man hittar gärna allting som är dåligt, för att det är för bra för att vara sant typ.
Då är det ofta gärna någon som säger då, de är bra, de doftar gott, men de sitter ju inte lika länge som en dyr parfym.
Alltså den, jag håller just nu på att göra typ så här, kan vi få ett claim på att våra parfymer kommer du inte känna någon skillnad på om du jämför dem med dyra parfymer.
Alltså jag håller på nu, det är en grekisk research, jag vet inte vad det heter, jag har fått det av vår säkerhetsbedömare.
Det är liksom en kontakt i Grekland som kan göra sådana här, vad heter det, kontroll eller utomstånd.
Ja, att de kan hjälpa oss att testa så att vi kan använda oss av ett claim.
Vi får ju kanske egentligen inte säga de doftar exakt likadant.
För det har vi ju inga claims på.
Inom kosmetik är det väldigt så man måste ha.
Men är det en så här, du kallar det för näsa, är det en person då som sitter och luktar en gång i timmen och bara, nej nu känns det som 75 procent.
Eller görs det datormässigt?
Det kommer ju bli konsument, det kommer vara typ 1000 personer som får testa.
Och så kanske man spröjar en byr och en billig och så får man liksom, jag vet inte hur det rent praktiskt går, jag håller på att kika på det nu i alla fall.
För jag blir så, jag går igång så mycket på när folk så här klagar på vår kvalitet och pratar om hur det funkar med parfym och man bara, asså ni har ingen aning om.
Asså, niche-parfymer är liksom många gånger bara bullshit.
De då, niche-parfymer är så här de allra dyraste parfymerna.
För det finns designer-parfymer som är det de ofta hittar på Kix.
Och då är det ofta typ så här, Hugo Boss har skapat en parfym, Prada har gjort en parfym, asså det är så här, ja, modermärken som då gör parfymer.
Och sen finns det någon som heter Niche.
Och vi är egentligen ett Niche-märke, för vi gör ju bara parfym, för det är ju egentligen definitionen av att vara Niche-märke.
Men ofta är ju Niche-märkena dyrare.
För de behöver ju liksom, ja, de säljer ju inte så mycket parfym, asså det är ju inte att sälja så mycket parfym som vi har gjort.
Och därför behöver de ju ha en jättehög prisbild för att de ska kunna göra sin marketing och tjäna sina pengar ändå.
Så Niche-parfym brukar ligga på mellan, ja men det finns ju billiga men vanligtvis är det liksom beredo, nu är inte beredo och Niche längre för de gör ju massa annat men det är uppemot liksom 1500 för 50 milliliter och upp till liksom, asså det finns inga begränsningar för vad det kan kosta.
Och så kommer vi in och säger att vi har samma kvalitet som de här dyra, men jag vet ju att det skiljer inte många kronor på vad våra parfymoljor kostar versus vad de här dyra husens oljor kostar.
Är det det som avgör en kvalitetsstämpel på parfym?
Är det oljan som är eller är det lite ingredienser eller vad är liksom?
Vad är kvaliteten?
Det är det som är för mig som ändå jobbat med det här i snart tio år, men vad är kvalitet då?
När folk klagar på kvaliteten, för kunden är ju kvalitet ett.
Hur doftade?
Doftade länge?
Hur är upplevelse?
Det är så många parametrar, det går inte heller säga vad kvalitet är.
Man kan ju säga att det är exklusiva oljor, men vad betyder det?
Och vad betyder det för kunden?
Att oljan är bara dyr, men luktar inte.
För det finns ingen sån här stämpel, men det här är kvalitetklass A och B.
Man kan ju prata om stämpel, att det är ifra approved, men det är ju så här International Fragrance Association.
Så det är ju typ så här mer att...
Du får betala lite pengar.
Nej men det är inte helt en annan.
Det är mer så här tillverknings...
Alla parfymer bör vara inom ifra.
För det är så mycket allerginer och allergiemmen och den typ.
Så att det är ifra approved är ju egentligen bara att vi möter liksom...
Säkerheten kring parfymen.
Så det finns liksom ingen så kvalitet...
Nej okej, man kan inte säga liksom...
Den här oljan är en basolja, det här är en dyr olja, det här är en...
Så vi använder den här olja.
Nej okej, ja.
Det är framför allt...
Men det spelar ju ingen roll om du har använt en asdyr olja med asdyra ingredienser.
Den doftar inte gott och den sitter inte.
Vad är det då?
Vad spelar då de här dyra ingredienserna för roll?
Alltså det är så...
Det är skitsvårt att fråga.
Men det jag tycker är tråkigt är att jag upplever att de gånger vi får kritik så är det för att våra parfymer inte håller.
Men det hade säkert kanske inte en dyr parfym med ett annat märke med exakt de här ingredienserna heller gjort.
För att det är liksom inte fel på ingredienserna i sig, utan det är inte fel på kunden, men det är mer så här, kunden passar inte med den här parfymen för att den kanske blir doftblind, eller så är kundens hud inte optimal för den kompositionen vi har i vår parfym.
Okej, ja.
Kan du känna att ni har fått kritik från andra aktörer som säljer parfymer?
Har du varit lite backhanded comments här och där eller?
Nej men ändå faktiskt inte.
Jag har ju jättemycket kontakter inom främst utåtställda ledet skulle jag väl säga.
Och det är ingen som har sagt något negativt.
Sen pratade de säkert bakom ryggen, men det är ingen som har sagt någonting till mig i alla fall.
Ja, de kanske inte har märkt hur fort det har gått än, så att de tänker fortfarande inte på det som ett hot, utan det kommer nästa år.
Ja, det är det.
Du, precis när vi började prata så ropade du något till din mamma.
Så din mamma jobbar på bolaget, din pappa jobbar på bolaget, din sambo jobbar på bolaget och du jobbar.
Är det någon mer släkting som har nånting?
Nej, det är inga mer släktingar.
Det är ju då min lillebror som, men nu är han heltidsanställd på sitt jobb, men innan han varit säsongsanställd och då har han bara jobbat under sommaren, och då har han varit perfekt och kunnat komma och packa under Q4.
Ja, hur är det att ha tre släktingar på samma kontor?
Jag tycker det är gött, och jag tror att alla i familjen tycker det är najs.
Vi umgås ju jättemycket privat också, så det är liksom smidigt att ha dem nära till hans.
Men du har också två barn, är det inte knepigt?
Folk frågar ju ofta om man kan jobba med sin sambo, det tycker jag inte är så konstigt.
Men att ha små barn med sin sambo och dra upp en uppstart i ett bolag, det tycker jag verkar krångligt.
För att barnen är sjuka eller, och det finns liksom ingen naturlig person som ska ta det då.
Hur löser ni det där?
I början var ju jag sjukt viktig för verksamheten.
Fredrik, han jobbade typ bara, hjälpte mig första året.
Sen var det såhär, nu hjälper du mig så mycket att nu kan du inte ha ett annat jobb liksom.
För han var också, han sålde sitt bolag så han hade inte riktigt ett fast jobb i början.
Första året då, när vi omsattade fem miljoner.
Men sen där i, jag tror det var mars eller någonting var det efter, så blev vi hamnen helt tidsanställd.
Och då fick han göra allt jag inte ville göra.
Men jag var...
Skysst arbetsbeskrivning ändå.
Ja, typ ekonomi och jag gjorde då inköp också för det tyckte jag ju var helt tråkigt.
Och då var jag ju liksom, jag gjorde ju all marketing, jag gjorde ju allting för att vi fick in försäljning.
Men nu när vi har anställt ett team och Fredrik är liksom vd och han sköter jättemycket med logistiken och har liksom mycket site och avtal.
Så nu om det är vabb då är det väl jag som åker på det.
Sen har vi ju min mamma då som, för jag har en dotter N4,5 och N2.
Så hon som är två har ju varit, det var då vi anställde mamma när vi fick Hailey som är två.
För att vi kunde ju inte ta föräldraledigt.
För att det hade också inneburit, vi hade kunnat ta föräldraledigt egentligen för att jag hade kunnat jobba bara 50 procent.
Men hade jag jobbat 50 procent, för när man har en bebis då kan man ju jobba liksom, alltså de sov ju första halvåret.
Men hade jag valt att ta ut föräldraledigheten så hade ju min stora dotter, det låg så elakt när man pratade om det så, men hon hade ju inte fått vara på förskolan.
Exakt, jag fattar precis.
Jag hade ju behövt liksom, den här tiden som jag hade då kunnat jobba, hade jag ju inte kunnat jobba.
För en, man var hon tre år, tre och ett halvt.
De är ju inte jätte självständiga vid den åldern.
De är ju inte heller alltid asköna.
Min yngsta nu är tre och han är tre och ett halvt.
Han är i ultra trots ålder.
Alltså det är helt, aldrig.
Den äldsta kan jag ha hemma och jobba och vabba.
Han kan sitta och liksom leka med leko eller vad som helst, men skulle jag passa båda två, då är det ju, fuck no.
Så första halvåret med Haley då, det gick ändå bra.
Vi hade med henne på första fyra månader, nej då sov de ju typ.
Och så då hade jag nästan med det mesta.
Det är ju om Fredrik lyssnar på det här kommer han att veta, för att han tycker inte så att vi har med henne i det här.
Men efter en viss tid så var vi så, alltså alla kände ju så att ingen får jobba, alla har Haley typ.
Åh gud det var så elakt när man pratade med henne så, men då bestämde vi såhär, måndagar då är jag hemma med Haley för att vi hade ju en leka.
Vi hade också kontor och lager 1 och då lå hon var ju där.
Så det var ju såhär, hon skrek hörde ju alla det eller hon gjorde ditt.
Så det var ju ändå så även om man inte hade henne så var det ju att när hon skrek så reagerade ju både jag, mamma och Fredrik, för att det var såhär, vem tar henne typ.
Så då bestämde vi att såhär, okej mamma har måndagar, jag har tisdagar, Fredrik onsdagar, mamma torsdag och jag har fredagar typ.
Och då var vi hemma med Haley, så då var man liksom inte på jobbet och lekte och umgick mig liksom att man, det var ju typ som att man var föräldraledig men vi var ju inte föräldralediga.
Ja, jag tycker, nu har du sagt ett par gånger såhär, ja det här låter redakt såhär.
Förskolan och hela barnomsorg, eller barnpassningen är ju inte anpassad för folk som driver bolag.
Alltså man kan ju inte vara ledig, det funkar ju inte på det sättet.
Vi fick ju skicka in ett arbetsgivarintyg att vi skulle ha sommarförskola.
Jag ba, vem ska skriva på det då?
Ja det kan du själv göra.
Okej, men varför måste jag lämna ett papper då?
Eller va?
Kan vi inte bara, jag jobbar i sommar, men det är bara tvungen att skicka in ett arbetsgivarintyg.
Jag har ju inget lön, nej men skriv det.
Ja, men vi är jättetacksamma för den förskolan varför den är faktiskt skitbra.
Och jag vet att barnen älskar att vara där så det känns tryggt.
Ja, fullförståelse.
Jag tror det finns många föräldrar därute som lyssnar på detta som fattar.
Jag tänkte på en annan grej.
Du nämnde lite EU och liknande.
I Sverige så, jag kan inte din verksamhet men det känns som att TikTok har varit den stora drivaren för Essence.
När du skalar utanför till andra länder, är det er drivare fortfarande?
Kan ni göra detta på engelska, franska, tyska?
Eller måste ni helt plötsligt börja göra en helt annan marknadsföringsmix?
Det är väl lite den typ nöten vi håller på att knäcka.
Men det är också den typ jättetur att jag och Fredrik då, för att han är ju inte den här galna grundläraren som helt plötsligt vill utomlands och kan hålla tillbaka lite i de bitarna.
För att vi får liksom inte tappa fokus, men även att man vill utomlands.
Men vi måste, nu håller vi på att testa.
Vi har testat Norge.
Vi har kört betalmarknadsföring i Norge i typ ett och ett halvt år.
Men nu, för typ två veck sedan, så var det så massa proppen bara lossnade typ.
Det kom jättemycket order från Norge, vilket är så roligt.
Där faller jag återigen tillbaka till att det är det här långsiktiga.
Vi har vatt i marknaden nu i ett och ett halvt år.
Vi har smått penetrerat marknaden på olika håll, främst via TikTok.
Men det är liksom...
Jag måste inse att det inte är så här, sätta på performance och så basar vi i en marknad.
Det är inte så vi vill bygga essens.
Även att man blir så lockad när man lyssnar på alla poddar och lyssnar på vår cakehand på TikTok som va ni kommer att roas på två om ni sätter igång ner i den marknaden.
Jag tror det kommer att krävas mer långsiktig bearbetning på de nya marknaderna.
Sen kommer vi att ha en TikTok-first approach på marknaderna vi går in i.
Men vi kommer också att tänka på att nu kommunicerar vi essent på ett sätt här i Sverige.
När vi går utanför Sverige, och Norge kommer att vara likt Sverige, men när vi går utanför, där de förstår vad vi säger på svenska, då vill vi porträttera oss mer som Scandi brand.
Lite annorlunda än, vi säger inte till Sverige att det är Scandi brand.
Så gör ju inga varumärken som är svenska som försöker utomlands.
Men vi tror att det är det som kan vara det som gör att det går bra för oss.
Och samtidigt då det här om en hög kvalitet till ett lågt pris kommer ju också vara en bidragande faktor i de andre marknaderna.
Men vi har inte bråttom.
Men när ni går in i Norge, pratar ni fortfarande på svenska eller har ni...?
Ja men vi har faktiskt testat på olika, vi har köpt norska, vi har köpt svenska, vi har köpt engelska.
Vi kan faktiskt inte se någon så signifikant skillnad i performance vilket språk vi kör på.
Så jag tror att mycket av det språket vi har nu är svenska på våra ads.
Sen har vi lite såhär MAMU-BC och kreatörer i Norge som pratar norska.
Och sen såhär Meta tror jag faktiskt också vi har norska, norsk copy på och sajten är i norsk copy.
Du känns ju fortfarande som du sa, lite småländsk.
Hur håller man liksom, hur håller man ödmjukheten igång?
Hur blir man inte förblindad av farten?
Och hajpad av sig själv, så att säga.
Det blir man väl stundtals, kan man väl bli så hajpad av sig själv.
Har du något exempel på när du har hajpade, när du bara, fad, nu betedde jag mig som ett asshole.
Det är ju mot mamma, jag bara, vad kan du ta av min disk?
Men jag tror, alltså såhär, jag fick faktiskt någon kommentar på TikTok, som jag blir genuint, typ ledsen av de kommentarerna, någon bara, äntligen nåt som ser igenom deras humble, de är ödmjuka typ.
Man bara, jag är så hun, jag är så mycket mig själv.
Jag tror att jag är ganska trygg i mig själv typ.
Så jag är alltid mig själv, alltså så som jag pratar med dig nu, det är liksom såhär jag är.
Eller det är typ såhär, jag hade pratat med dig om du satt så bredvid mig, jag hade pratat så med dig om vi spelade in en podd, eller om vi har tutat på middag.
Jag kan liksom inte vara något annat än det jag är på riktigt.
Sen vet jag att jag ska fortsätta vara mig själv, men jag tänker såhär, för mig är det vi har gjort med Sens, alltså jag skiter i, alltså det är skitkul, alltså prestationerna och så, det är jättebra men det definierar ju inte mig.
Även det gör ju det egentligen men det kommer säkert att förändra mig lite, men jag tror ändå inte att det kommer göra det typ, för jag känner mig ändå ganska grundad.
Jag vet inte.
Jag fattar, du var inte 18 år när det drog iväg, utan du har ändå hunnit leva lite liv, och man har fått ett par barn, och man har jobbat lite i arbetslivet.
Jag tror att det finns en nyttighet i det för att ge lite perspektiv på resan.
Eller så kan jag uppleva det i alla fall.
Jag tror också att det handlar om att jag är, först för att jag har skitdåligt minne, så skulle jag vara någonting som jag inte är.
Det blir ju skitjobbigt för då hade jag hela tiden glömt bort vem fan var jag nu när jag träffade den personen.
Det är nog en del i det, jag kan inte fejka någonting.
Jag kommer inte komma ihåg vad jag har fejkat och då blir det jättekonstigt.
Och sen är det just det här att, jag vet inte, mina värderingar i livet är ju inte kanske framgång och det som är det viktigaste, utan jag är mer så här att jag brinner för processerna och jag brinner för att utvecklas och det kommer inte försvinna bara för att det har lyckats.
Men nu är det så här, jag har börjat med min privata tiktok nu då för jag har ett nytt brand, jag kommer starta här i juli.
Och det liksom...
Varför?
Jag vet inte.
Känner du att, jag behöver ett nytt projekt eller vad?
Nej men alltså det är det, jag vet inte.
Ja för det är någonting jag typ va, fan det här vill jag ha och det finns inte, men då får jag väl bara göra det typ.
Det är liksom den här, jag vet inte, nyfikenheten och viljan och lusten och drivkraften som gör att man såhär, ja men fan jag testar det.
Alltså det kanske blir bra.
Det är liksom så, det blir så kravlöst också nu när man ändå har liksom, jobbat upp lite kapital, nu blir det här ett nytt bolag, men det kommer ändå vara under samma koncern typ, så att det blir inte så stor risk heller.
Om det är också så här, om jag nu kan självfulfilla ett behov för mig, så blir väl det jätte nice, och förhoppningsvis kanske det kan ändå gå liksom runt.
Det är väl inga målsättningar att det ska bli någon så unicorn eller någonting, utan det är så här, ja men det kanske kan funka.
Jag gillar det.
Det är klart man ska göra det.
Det är därför man har bolag, det är för att testa grejer man tycker är kul.
Annars var jag i syfte liksom.
Ni har köpt en egen lokal hörde jag.
Jag lyssnade på Framtidens e-handel här inför detta och då har ni köpt, det är ju min stora dröm, tänk på att köpa en egen lokal.
Men ni har också eget lager vilket jag älskar.
Alla ska ju köra 3PL nu och det är liksom ultratrendigt.
Men ni gör inte det och dessutom har ni ganska stark försäljning i Q4 om jag förstår rätt.
Är inte det skitjobbigt att driva eget lager då?
Alltså jag känner såhär, här borde ju Fredrik vara då.
Jag går ner där, spelar lite TikTok-videos och bara Åh går det bra?
Ja, vad bra!
Vi förvärvade den här fastigheten i oktober förra året kanske.
För det var ju att vi förvärvade ett bolag.
För att det är lättare tydligen.
För vi satt innan i kommunens lokaler, skitbilder hyra och vi var så, men här kan vi vara.
Det är ju astort jämfört med hemma i källaren.
Insåg jättesnabbt att när det här räcker inte så vi fick ta ett skepp till, som det var då en till port.
Och insåg direkt när vi hade tagit den att det var en till bredvid.
Vi tar båda.
Här kommer vi kunna vara skitlänge.
Sedan började vi bunkera upp för Q4 förra året.
Och bara, det är fullt.
Vad fan ska vi göra?
Vi får ju hitta en container eller någonting att ställa grejerna i för det går inte in med.
Och då hittar vi den här fastigheten och vi bor ju i Småland i Näsjö.
Det är ju inte så att folk står på kö för att köpa industrifastigheter här.
Jag tänkte säga att Näsjö är väl framförallt känt för att det är elfel där när man kör tåg.
Ja, exakt.
Det är dock ju väldigt tacksamt när man ska till Stockholm, det är ju bara snabbt tåget, två och en halvtimme.
Men, så då var vi och kollade först för att de skulle hyra ut den här fastigheten och då sa Fredrik sen att vi får inte bara köpa den då.
Och så sa de ja och så började den processen.
Och sen lagret var fortfarande kvar och packade alla julådrar nere på vår gamla lokal förra året.
Så det flyttade ju hit då i januari.
Alltså vi har ju lite annorlunda, vi har ju väldigt annorlunda packflöde.
Alltså delt har ju vi bara, nu har vi väl typ såhär 60 skus, eller vi har ju packat massa mer.
Men våra liksom hero-produkter som vi säljer mest av, det kanske är 60, 120, nej men säg att vi har typ 150 skus då.
Och våra produkter, jag har fått de faktiskt med dem hit för att du ska, alltså det är såhär, de är inte stora, de tar väldigt lite, det är ju inte såhär skrymmande eller vad heter, som jag antar att era produkter är, och tar mycket plats.
Vår ansnitt då, det är 250 kilo, och är en halv kubik, stort sett.
Ja, så vi har ju, ja men vi har ju liksom en packstation och sen bakom är alla produkter.
Så man går liksom inte med plocklistor eller någonting, utan man plockar order för order och färdigställer den liksom, varje gång den kommer upp i vårat backflöde.
Och vi har typ inte heller när, alltså nu kommer Fredrik och man lyssnar tycker jag, nu vet jag inte vad vi pratar om.
Men vi har ju inte dratt på oss några onödiga typ såhär system.
Eller vi använder oss liksom av, alltså vi packade ju i Shopify-appen, som kostar noll kronor, fram tills jag vet inte när, men det var liksom jättelänge.
Så vi har ju inte, och vi har på Snod som fraktalternativ.
Så det är inte heller massa dyra...
Instabio, nej jag ska inte säga, jag vet inte heller.
Ja men typ såhär, VMS-system.
Ja okej, ja.
Vi har liksom inga sådana, ofta är ju det då en katt liksom, och det har vi ju lyckats bygga utan.
Just för att vi har inga plocklistor, vi kan ändå packa liksom...
Är Fredrik lika, lika...
Jag har kommit på ett betrot lika kåt på att inte ha några kostnader som du är, eller har ni den här sortens diskussion, såhär, fan vi använder det här systemet så det blir noll.
Nej nej nej, han är ju värre än mig.
Ja vad trevligt.
Ja, så ibland kan jag vara så, ah men va fan.
För det är också så, alltså det är ju vi, vi har inte det här tänket, alltså till våra anställda är vi så, vad behöver ni?
Alltså det är inte så att vi, men det är mer typ såhär...
Och om då, säger ett packsystem tack.
Ja, då kommer vi säga nej.
Jag tror aldrig de kommer säga det, för det är ju liksom väldigt, alltså det är väldigt smooth.
Det är liksom, det är så enkelt.
Vi kan nästan, på tal om då hur vi överlever Q4, vi kan plocka nästan folk från gatan och sätta dem och packa.
För vi har också väldigt mycket, alltså vissa dagar så har vi en produkt och då kanske vi har sålt typ, om över helgen kanske vi ska packa tusen stycken av den här bästsäljan.
Då ställer man sig bara vid ett bord, tar en låda med den här bästsäljan och så bara matar man.
Sen kan vi massutskriva den här laben och så bara blir det att man, så på en timma kanske den personen har gjort, nu vet jag faktiskt inte hur många man gör på en timma, men det finns ju, vi vet ju exakt hur många en person gör på en timma.
När vi då får in jättemånga ordrar, då är det så lätt att ta in någon som gör den här processen och så blir vi av med jättemånga ordrar som är de här enkla.
Sen har vi insett, vi gjorde en påsk på tal om rabatter, vi har faktiskt haft gåvor med köp, det har vi sträckt oss till och haft några gånger.
I påskas så hade vi påskäggsjakt på sajten, så då gav vi bort en liten påse med tre tester i sidan när man köpte, när man handlade hos oss.
Och man hittade det där påskäget.
Det var det sjukaste.
Man blir ju då och bara, få helvete när man kör rabatt, det är helt sjukt.
För det är ju en form av rabatt, det är det ju faktiskt.
Men inte den här discount-rabatten.
Då hade vi ju, då satsade vi på prov.
För då var det ju det här, vi kunde massutskriva till en viss del, men det som måste packas i vårt flöde, det var där lite flaskhalsen blev.
För vi hade inte räknat med att det skulle gå så bra som det gjorde.
Men nu vet vi, det var en jättebra lärdom för nu håller vi på och optimerar inför Q4, tack vare den här grejen som hände i Boska så att vi kan hantera de här vikarna.
Fördelen är att vi också har julkalendrar som vi packar nu.
Jag tror att det är typ, fan jag kan inte siffra, men kanske 600-700 timmar på julkalenderpackning.
Vilket är väldigt tacksamt då kan man ju ta in extra personal och lära upp, men också packa de här julkalendrarna.
Ja, det verkar verkligen ha blivit en grej som har slagit inom, jag vet inte, ett visst segment julkalendrar.
Jag tycker jag hör det hela tiden att satsa på det, det kan man verkligen sälja.
Jag får fundera på hur vi ska lösa den utmaningen.
Jag har en sista fråga som jag tycker är jätteintressant, för jag tror att det är många dröm.
Jag hörde att ni skulle testa att jobba i Spanien på distans.
Har ni gjort det?
Ja, vi kom hem första juli, så var vi där från första april.
Hur gick det?
Det gick jättebra.
Vi har ett ställe i Schönggerola som ligger innan Marbella.
Barnen gick i svensk förskola där nere.
Lilla Snigel heter den, den är supermysig.
Det är ett par som driver den.
De är fem anställda, de är ganska många anställda.
Det är väl ett tjugotal barn typ.
En av de här som äger det är kock.
Han lade jättegod mat i barnen varje dag.
Det gick bra men det är skillnad.
Det tar ett tag att komma in i lugnt jättet.
Förskolan öppnar nio, de ska äta ett frukost hemma på morgonen.
Då åker man och lämnar dem förskolan.
Sen ska man själv äta lunch och hämta dem i fyra.
Det tog lite tid för oss att känna att man hinner jobba riktigt.
Hemma lämnar man vid halv åtta.
Man hinner plöja in några timmar innan lunch.
Jag gillar innan lunch jobbet.
Efter lunch är jag inte alls produktiv.
I Spanien är det efter lunch man har sin tid.
Kan ni göra det även när barnen är äldre?
När kan ni sluta lämna på en sån skola?
Det finns ju svensk skola också.
Vi ska ner igen i vår.
April till juli blir det den också.
Det är ju lite nice leather där nere.
Vi har inte faktiskt satt ut någon semester i sommar.
Men där nere blir kvällarna längre.
Man hinner hitta på grejer med barnen.
Det är fint väder.
Man får ju lite annan livskvalitet.
Sen älskar jag när vi kom hem vad jag såg.
Det är så skönt där hemma.
Jag tycker typ om att man kan göra så som vi har gjort nu när barnen går på förskolan och få lite av båda.
För jag vet inte faktiskt om jag skulle känna att jag vill bo där nere.
För jag älskar att vara på jobbet och jag älskar att vi håller på med det här kontoret.
Det finns så mycket grejer här som ger mig så mycket energi att jag vet inte om jag är redo att lämna det för en flytt i Spanien.
Hur löser ni contentmaskineriet på under tiden?
Jag spelar in ganska mycket videos där nereifrån.
Sen har tjejerna fått steppa upp och vara lite mer närvarande.
Vad tycker de om det då?
De tycker det är kul.
Det är bara tidsmässigt, det tar ju väldigt mycket tid.
Men de tycker det är kul.
Jag förstår.
Jonna, stort stort stort tack för att vi fick komma med dig i podden.
Det här ska bli en jävla spännande resa att följa när de står den.
Jag uppskattar detta, vi hugger dig innan du blir för kaxig.
Hahaha, hoppas inte det sker.
Hej.
Jag tänkte säga att ni sker väl framförallt känt för att det är elfel där när man kör tåg.